yesterday we looked at this bizarre
unhinged erratic letter the Donald Trump
sent to Nancy Pelosi on the eve of his
impeachment which came yesterday the
letter was truly a joke that couldn't be
further from being presidential it
looked like a kid wrote it it was
riddled with exclamation points it was
filled with lies and distortions and
nonsense it made Donald Trump look quite
frankly out of his mind
but the clowns at Fox News all day
yesterday were rapidly praising the
letter as just out of this world it was
even likened to the Gettysburg Address
can you imagine this should be
interesting because it really
illustrates the difference that I've
been pointing to between Donald Trump
and Richard Nixon's impeachment Nixon
didn't have the benefit of a 24/7 news
cycle that would defend everything he
does no matter what combined with social
media echo chambers to then signal boost
those absolutely fact-free defenses so
let's go through this let's start with
Lou Dobbs who hosts a total pro Trump
propaganda show on a channel called Fox
Business Network here's Lou Dobbs
speaking of corruption the radical Dems
and their efforts to overthrow this
president right and it is the president
today wrote a beautiful letter a
terrific letter to Nancy Pelosi which
she responded to by saying it was
ridiculous
sick in point of fact it was elegant I
it was comprehensive and it put her and
the radical Dems who have attacked this
president mercilessly for over three
years precisely where they should be and
that is and in the focus of history for
decades to come
apparently an exclamation point riddled
life filled screed is eloquent to Lou
Dobbs and Lou Dobbs would know about
good writing right I mean he's a real uh
he's just another Ernest Hemingway type
for sure we can go to Lou Dobbs for
opinions about literature anyway later
Lou Dobbs
brings on a guest who likened the
address as I mentioned before to the
gettysburger who'd likened the letter to
the Gettysburg Address take a listen to
this writing a six-page letter to pelosi
gave her an opportunity an off-ramp if
you will
at the conclusion of that letter and
then she responds with a comment to a
reporter with others present saying it
was a ridiculous letter that's her
response and the ignorance is
institutionalized amongst the the party
of hate now obviously everybody should
go read that letter it is a massive it
is the Gettysburg Address of smear job
false accusations what a response at the
historical document Schumer saying we've
got to have witnesses these folks are
living in an alternate reality and I
don't say that as an insult sometimes
when we say they're in another world
we're saying it in an insulting way but
it is another reality they have crafted
an echo chamber where between if you
watch Fox News and you just have your
social media echo chambers and you
repeat and follow what Donald Trump does
you are in another reality completely
this this seems like the analysis of the
Trump letter that the world is laughing
at then in comes commentator Amy
Tarkanian who said that she just loved
the letter and she's thrilled that
Donald Trump wrote it this is a sickness
this is determined ego it is unrelenting
hatred of the American Way I loved every
word of his letter and I'm glad that he
wrote it so then that way when when we
do look down in history back at all the
wonderful things that he was able to
accomplish despite the Democrats
obstruction I think it was it was
well-written and it was definitely worth
it well written there it is again well
written now like what is wrong with
these people
that you could say you agree with the
sentiment of the letter but to call it
well-written is just odd then you had
maybe the chief FoxNews propagandist
Sean Hannity
of course ecstatic calling it a powerful
scathing beat down of a letter by Donald
Trump because breaking moments ago the
president well he's fighting back and
what is a powerful scathing beat down
the president accused Speaker Pelosi of
declaring open war on American democracy
with a partisan impeachment crusade that
represents an unprecedented and
unconstitutional abuse of power
by Democratic lawmakers powerful
scathing beat down then you had Laura
Ingraham promote the letter as Trump
teaching Republicans how to fight and
being hard-hitting now I read the entire
letter it's it's hard-hitting but I feel
like a good friend of mine in Florida
very politically connected said the
president is teaching Republicans how to
fight they simply like Mitt Romney's
Rules of Order and we're gonna be very
old my dear friend and from New York we
respect you so much but I have a slight
disagreement equivalent he's gonna take
you come at him with a club and he's
gonna come at you with something bigger
and harder and a congressman McClintock
so now understand the propaganda cycle
Trump sends out the insane letter the
letter is truly the rantings of a madman
it's the that's I don't know how else to
more concisely describe it everybody on
Fox News sucks up the Trump which is the
second round of disinformation and the
propagandizing then Donald Trump tweets
about how people love the letter which
is the third round of propaganda this is
what Nixon didn't have in the 1970s
Trump ended up tweeting good marks and
reviews on the letter I sent to Pelosi
today she is the worst no wonder people
like her and crying Chuck Schumer DC has
been such a mess for so long and that
includes the previous administration who
and now we know for sure spied on my
campaign yet lies of course and the
cycle continues dragging along the
trumpets in this endless barrage of
propaganda and disinformation this is
why I've been saying for months now when
we speculated about Trump's impeachment
and early on there was the idea that you
know if the Republicans turn against him
in the Senate maybe he would also resign
like Richard Nixon did Richard Nixon
didn't have what from past
Trump has Twitter which for all its
failings does allow him to get directly
into he's able to inject the propaganda
cycle with energy by tweeting his
sycophants in the media Fox News Fox
Business one American news you know all
these different ones they take what
Trump starts and turn it into this is
the best thing ever this guy's brilliant
this is so strong everything about the
great Trump then says I'm so pleased
that people are saying that I'm doing
good things and then meanwhile because
Facebook knows the type of stuff that
you're more likely to watch like cher or
whatever you exclusively over time are
shown more and more of that stuff and
your filter bubble is simply never
pierced this is a major difference from
Richard Nixon in the 1970s I don't know
that we have the ability to say for sure
were it not for social media and Fox
News Trump may have resigned already in
the way that Richard Nixon did Trump's a
completely different person than Nixon
the circumstances are certainly
different but there's no question that
this entire presidency from the
beginning would have gone completely
differently if it did not have the
benefit of 24-hour sycophant except
right-wing news and social media echo
chambers that's for sure the next video
is coming soon but before you go to that
please hit subscribe and like we're
running a test we believe that if
everybody does this
this will hugely boost us in YouTube's
algorithm and then everybody wins I'll
report back to you how this works make
sure before you go on to that next video
hit subscribe hit like thank you so much